[Music]  we got a great show tonight and hey Jeff  is there someone who could grab me like  a smoothie or something yeah cuz I just  I'll do it  wait why didn't send me other line yet  you can you do me a favor grab me like a  strawberry yogurt smoothie little honey  in it you got it all right cool bill  tell everybody just hanging around I  have you ever seen bill told but I'm an  active person always on the go that's  why we enjoyed Lala's yogurt smoothies  oh crap Conan do we have a strawberry  for him yeah Oh blank commercial friends  I'm sorry bill what the hell was that a  commercial for a la la la la yoghurt  smoothies what look at this I want  everyone to see this is the card he  can't  this is what he can't read its are you  reading off that one I was reading up  nuns  well you're allowed to use those you  know like what you want a different  color of crayon maybe  you